[Music]
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast today on the show is Dr Ayman
you may have seen him before you may
have followed him on social media he is
helping people understand how to have a
healthier brain he is a psychiatrist and
he's also specializes in brain function
has 10 clinics I recently went and had a
brain scan done by him and it shows just
blood flow it shows where my brain is
lighting up it shows the shape of my
brain and whether or not there's holes
or receding areas such fascinating stuff
thankfully my brain looks pretty good
but it can always be better what we
talked about was just like what it takes
to make your brain better what makes
your brain bad what your brain actually
does and why you want it to be a healthy
brain why do you want blood flow like
what does that do and then of course we
got into some sports stuff we got it
into concussions CTE we touched on
Psychopaths serial killers so we just
sort of explored all the areas where you
can see what reality manifests as a
result of an unhealthy brain this is his
uh his book you happier you can check
out me on his show as well going into
what my brain looked like please hit
subscribe and the bell for notifications
when an episode comes out and please let
us know in the comments what your
thoughts are and what it is that you're
doing for your brain health thank you
for listening you have a very unique
introduction to people you're like I'm
gonna look at the inside of your brain
and then the outside yeah my wife tells
the story that when I met her I really
really liked her and I'm like you
haven't seen the clinic you said no
one's ever asked to see my naked brain
first okay you said that the brain is
the most complicated organ in the
universe is that true it's true it's
also the most amazing organ in the
universe it's two percent of your body's
weight but uses 20 to 30 percent
of the calories you consume so it's the
most expensive real estate
in your body and the purpose of the body
is to carry around the brain is there an
approach that we have to life that could
be tuned differently with that in mind
well everything it changes When You
Believe
that the brain is involved in everything
you do how you think how you feel how
you act how you get along with other
people it's the organ of intelligence
character love and every single decision
you make and when it works right you
work right and when it doesn't you don't
and with that belief why would you ever
let a child hit a soccer ball with their
head why would you allow
developing brains to
be inside helmets and slam them up
against other people
yeah that's my parents it just doesn't
make
sense when you think of it from a
neuroscientist's perspective
and as a psychiatrist I get to see the
Fallout of when people hurt
their brains but ultimately brain health
starts with love
that you know I often say Freud was
wrong penis envy is not the cause of
anybody's problem I've not seen it once
in 40 years uh although you may have a
different perspective being a female in
a very male dominated
sport
um but it's brain Envy if if we learn to
really love and care
for our brains our society will be so
much better
okay like outline the most important
things then if you were if you were if
that's the truth if we're moving forward
we're going we're going to make we're
gonna we're gonna create brain Envy by
taking care of our brains what is it
that we need to do we'll start there
what do we what is it what what are some
basics
so I think of it as three things
it's Brandon we gotta care about it
avoid things that hurt it you got to
know the less yeah and do things that
help it again yeah know the list and
when you and I were together we talked
about bright Minds right that if you
want to keep your brain healthy or
rescue it if it's headed for trouble we
have to prevent or trade the 11 major
risk factors workers that steel
your mind but ultimately I worked with
BJ Fogg at Stanford for six months on
creating tiny habits for brain health
okay and the mother habit the most
important
habit is this three second question you
just ask yourself is this good for your
brain or God for it and if you know the
less and quite frankly most second
graders know the list I went to my
daughter's second grade class and I
wrote 20 things on the board and I'm go
separate them for me good for your brain
or bad for your brain and they got 19
out of 20 things right okay the only
thing that missed was orange juice which
is bad for your brain because it's too
much sugar but other than that you know
people sort of have a sense alcohol is
really not great for your brain
marijuana is not really great for your
brain hitting soccer balls with your
heads probably bad for your brain if you
know your brain is soft and your skull
is hard
um
but bright Minds for me it helps bring
it home in a more scientific way
and so for example B is for blood flow
low blood flows the number one brain
Imaging predictor of Alzheimer's
and you had beautiful blood flow which
was a huge shock uh given your history
right I agree even Yesterday Mindy
adjusted my neck and she was like oh
you're Atlas and she like adjusted me
and um and uh you know even from that
perspective it seems like you know that
would pinch things off too you know what
are the things that lower blood flow
um not exercising right excessive
caffeine nicotine
[Music]
um
erectile dysfunction and I don't know if
you know but the statistics are scary
of 40 year olds have erectile
dysfunction 40 of 40 year olds
70 of 70 year olds and I'm like no I'm
not okay with this but it comes from our
poor diets our lack of exercise our
incidence of diabetes and
um if you want to increase blood flow so
each of these risk factors go well how
do you prevent it right
um exercise probably the most important
thing you can do yeah Beats cayenne
pepper the supplement genko
um all of these things can increase
blood flow and so I want people to have
blood flow Envy uh because just so
important so whatever is good for your
heart is good for your brain and
whatever's bad for your heart is bad for
your brain and it turns out sexual
function and it seems like a basic
question but what is the what is the
brain's function and I'm only I'm asking
that because well one it's just I'm just
kind of curious what your answer is but
also there's just so much curiosity
around like how the Body Works what is
our reality Consciousness and how
everything plays in so what do we know
because there's a lot that we don't know
about the brain is that accurate too you
know people say that a lot but there's a
whole bunch we do know
and if you heard certain parts of your
brain you tend to have certain problems
so if you hurt the front part of your
brain
well it's the executive part of the
brain
it's involved in focus and forethought
judgment impulse control
organization planning empathy learning
from the mistakes you make so what I
like to teach people to do is how to
have better funnel quotes and in that
way they have a better life
because they know what they want
and they see the future on how to get it
and then they act in ways that are
consistent
with their goals so for all of my
patients I do an exercise I love called
The one-page Miracle on one piece of
paper write it down what do you want
relationships work money physical
emotional spiritual health what do you
want and then another tiny habit after
you do that is before you go to do
anything or say anything you just go
well does it fit does my behavior said
the goals I have for my life and so many
people have never like if you have a
good business
you have a plan on what are you going to
do this quarter and this year in three
to five years from now
most of my patients I've seen over the
years they have no plan
and so they end up going from crisis to
crisis but that's what your frontal
lobes do
is they plan they organize and they keep
you on track and when they're hurt
from a head injury or heavy metal
exposure or a near drowning episode sure
their level of impulsivity is high
and they don't get their goals so it's
sort of like you drive it
without good breaks
and so if you imagine yourself in a race
car at the top of a mountain
and you don't have good brakes you're
not getting to the bottom and you may
die not in one piece that's what happens
when people have low frontal lobe
function now if you have high frontal
lobe function it's like the brakes
always on so those are people who have
OCB yeah and they can't
it's it's they can't stop stop it
themselves to either do a ritual or a
bad thought and so it's always about
balance
so so the purpose of the brain is to be
aware and control your life to think
it's to feel it's to act it's to
interact when it's not healthy and I've
seen a whole bunch of unhealthy brains I
have over 100 murderers that we've
scanned their brains are not healthy
yeah well I was very curious about that
that was um definitely I wanted to get
to that with this Dahmer documentary on
Netflix being so popular I think it even
I think I even saw it said that it was
one of the most popular on Netflix uh
Netflix history what is it that you've
seen with
um evil people
sociopaths Psychopaths serial killers I
mean I guess I can't say that you I
don't know if you've had serial killers
in there before but what have you seen
with um the brains of people actually
have you ever have you ever been able to
take someone from a prison or someone
that has been sentenced for something
extreme and and done any testing on
those brains lots of them
yeah no it's not uncommon if you're in
the clinic that somebody shows up in an
orange jumpsuit in handcuffs and
shackles and
um I had one guy with a cobra tattoo on
his skull he was a pretty wicked at
least his behavior was wicked and you
know what I learned
is the people that do bad things
often not always but often have Bad
Brains and so I've testified in death
penalty cases and
um you might remember Kip King Cole who
in 1998 murdered his mother and father
so he brought weapons to school he got
arrested his mom and dad picked him up
from jail at six o'clock at night and
sometime between six o'clock at night
and eight o'clock the next morning he
murdered his mom and dad and then he
went to his high school in Springfield
Oregon and shot 25 people
um and based on my work they scanned him
in Oregon Health Sciences University and
they sent me the scans 15 years old it's
got the most damaged 15 year old brain
I'd ever seen and and you know he
murdered his mother so I don't exactly
know why but it could have been a lack
of oxygen at Birth it could have been an
infection it
um
it was something poisoning that Poor
Boy's brain now I always think of people
in four big circles we have a biology so
the physical functioning of our brain
and body we have a psychology which is
how we think and our development we have
a Social Circle
um what's going on in our life right how
are we doing in school what are
relationships like do we have money and
a spiritual Circle which is so why the
heck do you care you know why do you
think you're on the planet what is your
deepest sense of meaning and purpose and
I see you as a very purposeful person
when you think of serial killers
they have problems in all four of those
circles
because quite frankly you can have a bad
brain and never do anything bad
and so kept what I got to know about him
is there a trouble in all four of those
circles his purpose in life was to be a
mass murderer
um he had very bad thinking and was
isolated and disconnected and yeah I
scanned Byron Katie she talked about it
publicly she's a spiritual teacher and
she had a terrible looking Brent and
before she had her Awakening she woke up
on the floor of a halfway house in 1986
and realized that when she believed her
thoughts she suffered but when she
didn't believe her thoughts she didn't
suffer I mean it's so cool so powerful
she had a bad brain but a wonderful
spirit if you will yeah and so so it's
not all brown but whenever you see
someone who does something bad yeah we
should ask ourselves the question it's
what's going on in their brain
and uh
it's fascinating like Dahmer I would
have loved to have Dahmer's brains I
have fantasy brains like you know guys
have Fantasy Women I have fantasy brains
did you watch the Dahmer did you watch
it I've watched part of it okay well
dark yes and a lot of people can't get
past the first episode like a struggle I
watch the whole thing but at the I I
don't think it's too big of a deal but
at the end
um they there's a there's a one of the
parents wants to have the brain for
research to try and understand what
really happened with them but Dahmer's
will said that he wanted to be cremated
as quickly as possible and so you know
the scene at the end is the brain going
into the you know
Into the Fire
well I've done
um I have the spec scan on a serial
killer from New York uh the Son of Sam
and he has very damaged frontal lobe
and find out your frontal lobes are
where you have empathy
and forethought and judgment now some of
these serial killers think Ted Bundy
they're really effective so you can't
argue that they couldn't plan you know
that yeah
was impeccable right but there's also
something fascinating to me called the
arousal template so why would you get
off on killing and there's something in
their childhood where when they killed
something there was some excitement
involved in that and I think with Dahmer
that was in fact the case yeah with the
animals and yeah you know it was kind of
funny did it with his dad and it was
interesting and exciting and he had a
poor childhood with parents that left
him alone a lot and you know there's a
lot of factors there
um so you know why does someone develop
what
pure you know we call them paraphilias
that one guy that would have sex with
cows and it's like okay what's that
about it's because at some point in
their past an incident happened that
arouse them their brain produced a lot
of dopamine and they're like oh I like
this so it could be shoes or cows or
whatever unusual thing I mean sometimes
it's violence wow so what is it that
makes the brain such a recorder such a
memory recorder
wow that's sort of the cool part that's
also a curse
and uh the hippocampus is one of the
major memory centers in the brain and it
tends to be larger in females which is
why she still remembers that bad thing
you did 15 years ago
um where you're having trouble
remembering the day you're married right
and the hippocampus hippocampus sits in
front of the pineal gland sort of in the
middle of the brain is that right so
think of it as right behind your eyes
okay so it's it's toward the inside so
there's love one left and one right on
the inside okay of your temporal lobes
and it's right next to the amygdala so
the amygdala
is uh an area that often responds to
threat and Stress and Anxiety the
hippocampus is involved with mood and
memory but also spatial awareness and
it's really cool
in that the hippocampus is one of the
only areas of the brain that continues
to make new neurons throughout life so
every day you make about 700 new baby
hippocampal stem cells so think of the
hippocampus which is Greek for seahorse
because it's in the shape of a seahorse
so every day you're making about 700 new
baby seahorses every day and I use this
analogy with my drug addicts I'm like
you know if you don't stop you're
murdering the baby seahorses and for my
patients who are animal lovers they just
get so mad at me it's like Dr Raymond
that's so unfair you know I love animals
no and that never drops off you're
saying that's a status off but while my
daughters is more likely to stick than
mine yeah much younger and theoretically
should have better blood flow but it's
why I have blood flow envy that even at
68 I want to have a young brain because
I want those hippocampal cells to live
okay
things because it'll stick things stick
of something you learn something you
hear so new learning helps grow them
exercise helps grow them so if you
exercise and then learn something new
well that's the best way to do it so
play table tennis and then work on your
new language or your piano whatever it
is you're learning to grow your brain
and and you know it goes back to avoid
bad do good so if we think of VR
retirement and aging if you're in a job
that does not require new learning
you're more likely to get Alzheimer's
disease because you're not activating
and if if you think of you know a
discussion with you which I think is
very important to have for professional
athletes is well they retire often in
their late 20s or early 30s right and
it's like if they don't go to what's
next yeah they get depressed in large
part because they're not feeding their
hippocampus and those seahorses are
dying because they're not getting the
nourishment of new learning and many
athletes when they retire they don't
continue exercising and so when I did my
big NFL study we've scanned and treated
300 NFL players uh half of them were
obese
because they're like still eating what
they ate when they were blamed but not
exercising with that intensity sure well
and also if they're like an o-line guy
they have to keep their weight up
because weight moves weight you know
like when you lean in when you lean in
wearing weighing 325 versus 175 or 225
is a big difference
um what did you yeah the CTE thing
really like intrigues me of course
um so you know being someone that drove
with helmets basically if you have to
wear a helmet it's probably dangerous
for your brain all right well and people
have the idea that helmets protect you
they actually protect you from Skull
fractures they don't protect you from
concussions because inside your skull
your brain is not fixed it floats and so
if you hit a wall at 200 miles an hour
well you're going 200 miles an hour
which means your brain is going 200
miles an hour and then all of a sudden
movement stops and so inside your brain
it's very much like shaken baby syndrome
which is is definitely not a good thing
you had an amazingly beautiful brain so
for some people
um their brain is resistant and what I
mean there's a term I love called brain
Reserve okay which is the extra tissue
you have to deal with whatever stress
comes your way okay and so some people
go into the wall and they're permanently
damaged and other people not why it
depends on the health of the brain they
brought into that accident
and so if your parents wanted you if
they ate reasonably healthy if they gave
you nutrition educational opportunities
if they loved you and weren't
chronically unhappy with each other so
putting you under chronic stress when
you go into that accident your brain's
much healthier than so for example I
adopted my two nieces
mother drank when they were pregnant so
right away they have less brain reserve
and then they moved a lot and there was
chronic fighting and stress so when I
had adopted them we had a whole bunch of
work to do to boost their reserve and
help them live you know healthier lives
yeah yeah well what's the correlation
between
um like CTE and
the aggressive nature that comes out it
sounds almost like a sociopath or
someone that does bad things because
there's lots of you know there's stories
of of former players you know they
commit suicide they they they seem to
act out of the ordinary in some kind of
way
um what area of the brain is is
responsible for that and what is the
what are the findings with um all of
your research with CTE
so I published four studies on our NFL
work
and and the most common finding is
decreased activity in the front part of
their brain so forethought judgment
impulse control
planning empathy
um decreased activity in both their
temporal lobes memory mood stability
temper control and decreased activity in
their cerebellum in the back bottom part
of their brain and that's sort of the
quality control part of your brain it's
sort of the last check before a thought
gets out of your mouth or a behavior
gets out of your body
and
um and these are like incredibly
um
coordinated
athletes you know their reaction times
were just off the charts even seeing me
many years later
um
but the cool thing is when I started my
study
the NFL was an active denial that they
had a problem
and
I'm like okay somebody's got to do
something about this
so clear like let's not lie about it
playing football is a brain damage it's
sport because if you don't admit you
have a problem you can't do anything to
solve the problem but what we discovered
that I'm so excited about is 80 of our
players got better when we put them on a
brain rehabilitation program how cool is
that amazing because that sound it
sounded like to me when I heard about
CTE I was like like the damage is done
you know like that there's just you know
you have CTE
um but that is amazing it's reversible
and you got it the earlier you start the
better and the more see a lot of players
won't come and get checked because
they're like I don't want to know I have
CPE that is permanent and irreversible
that's the lore going around our society
right right and I'm like no and we
publish this in a scientific journal 80
of our players get better not a lot of
athletes are reading scientific journals
no that's true I was a consultant on the
movie concussion with Wilson yeah I
watched it of course and I was actually
written into the script Peter lamisman's
the writer and director of concussion
and he he's like you're like the only
one talking about Hope and so I have the
joy of being written into a script and
the pain of being written out because
they decided it was going to be a movie
of David versus Goliath with Dr romolo
Who's A friend of mine against the NFL
and I keep bugging Peter and I'm like
you need to do concussion too you need
to tell people there's hope that if you
do the right things you can be better
obviously the earlier you start
the batter and a lot of sophisticated
players actually have hyperbaric
chambers in their homes yeah so I love
that I just did a presentation for the
coaching staff the Miami Heat and they
actually told me about some of the
players who have hyperbaric chambers in
their homes yeah well you know I have
one I love that and in our conversation
it was such a high recommendation for
people
um and why is that so good why is hyper
I mean is hyperbaric chamber something
you think that like generally speaking
should be part of it should be everyone
should be thinking about using it or is
there a certain something some some
symptom or a trigger or maybe a you know
maybe being a former former athlete is
there is there something that you would
say if you have low blood flow
hyperbaric oxygen is really good I
recommend it to almost everybody that I
see on imaging has low blood flow if
you've had a concussion and even now the
and probably when you were racing the
concussion protocol was Wrath and I'm
like that is just so dumb you know you
have to put the brain in a healing
environment
and that's not risk
um so I think for concussions it's
awesome yeah for people who've had
Strokes it's been found to be really
helpful after you've had surgery so a
lot of people don't know
that general anesthesia can be bad for
the brain so if we go back to Bright
Minds the t is toxins
and
children who have general anesthesia
have a higher incidence of ADHD and
learning problems older adults who have
anesthesia have a higher incidence of
dementia that anesthesiologists never
tell you um we're going to do general
anesthesia and I may lower your IQ
points like 18. why does it reduce blood
flow what is it about anesthesia
you know it's not the short-term
anesthesia like you know they give you
pro football for a dental procedure it's
the general anesthesia for some
vulnerable people it decreases blood
flow significantly
and like I'm a psychiatrist why do I
care about that because if you have low
blood flow you're more likely to get
depressed you're more likely to have
brain fog you're more likely to drop and
lose words I want to clarify concussions
real quick because I feel like for me a
lot of people have asked me
how many concussions have you had and
I'm like
I mean it's got to be a scale I'm like I
don't know I've had like two or three
that I had like symptoms from meaning
that night or yeah it's usually that
like sort of like isolated to the day
but I I definitely had some some effect
but I was like I also hit the wall
probably I don't know
60 70 80 times I don't know I hit the
wall a lot I raced for 27 years I
crashed in go-karts I crashed in race
cars so I'm curious because I think that
this is an applicable question to
football or soccer or anything else
where there's not a symptom but you have
an impact to the head you butt heads
when you're tackling you hit it you you
take a header on a soccer ball whatever
it may be
what is it that actually
deems an impact a concussion
well technically it's when you have when
you're symptomatic really but the
question is what does more damage the
big hits or the little hits
okay Joe Lewis actually said it best the
famous heavyweight champion boxer he
said it's not the big hits that cause
dementia it's the thousands of little
hits and so if you think of Navy SEALs
for example they do thousands of
breaching exercises where they're
blowing up things
and that is a sub concussive blow you
think of an offensive line person in
practice and games you end up with
thousands right yes yeah and we looked
at you know on a football field what's
the worst position you know what pattern
gives you the worst brain and it was
offensive lineman
the second one was linebackers
and then defensive lineman
um and then tight ends uh quarterbacks
and defensive backs actually had the
best brains uh because yes they get big
hits but they don't get the thousands of
little so those aren't concussions then
so you're but you're what you're saying
though is those aren't concussions but
they are brain injuries they're
sub-concussive blows and it's like so
what happens in a concussion well the
brain starts to swell
um blood vessels get ripped so you get
these micro bleeds neurons tear
and
um it's not a good thing right so if you
think of the brain as the consistency of
soft butter tofu custard somewhere
between egg whites and jello doesn't
seem like I should have taken butter on
a 240 mile an hour ride just saying
and your skull is not
smooth inside it has sharp bony ridges
why and so you know God and I have had
this discussion several times it's like
why didn't you put bumper guards over
that sharp bony Ridge that's right next
to the amygdala or in racing they'd be
soft they would be safer barriers like
they used to have walls and you just
crash into it and then they created
safer Bears which was a wall in front of
the wall that had essentially it was
movable it wasn't locked down and it and
it any and it compressed into foam for
safer barriers athletes are so important
um and just giving a little forethought
to their health is is so important I
I've had season tickets to the Lakers
for like ever and when Kobe Bryant was
playing with Lamar Odom it came out and
it was 2007. the NBA Championship that
Lamar Odom was eating 80 dollars of
candy a week
and so I wrote an op-ed piece that got
published in the New York in the Los
Angeles Times like why are why do they
not have a nutritionist for somebody
they're paying 14 million dollars a year
and not teaching them and and I bring up
that story specifically in the
concussion they did a study with rods
and
um they gave rats ahead and not very
nice but they were doing a study and
they gave one group of rats their normal
healthy diet the other group of rats
their normal healthy diet plus fructose
or fruit sugar
and then they measured them at three
weeks
at three weeks the rats with the healthy
diet without the sugar could run mazes
they already knew so their brains were
healing the rats who got
their healthy diet plus fructose were
still confused
that Sugar
decreases healing because it's
pro-inflammatory
um and it disrupts brain function
so why is Gatorade on the sidelines
right in a brain damaging sport it's
it's it's just nuts well should they
have from a neuroscience perspective I
mean you know I mean they can have
electrolyte
powders that don't have added red dye
sodium just yeah yeah some kind of
sodium supplement that will help you
retain water and stay hydrated so
um so what is the right diet then I mean
this is always such a Hot Topic anyone
listening is probably interested in
health and wellness and I feel like Diet
is one of those things that comes and
goes and waves and Ebbs and flows and
new stuff emerges and something that was
great is horrible and the next thing
comes along so what is the like what is
the most healthy diet for your brain
so I think really all effective
long-term diets say the same things
that high quality calvaries and calories
matter
um but the quality actually matters more
in a society where 72 percent of us are
overweight we're consuming like for
example
Americans are drinking nearly 500
calories a day where in 1982 that number
was 225 calories a day that extra 275
calories
puts 25 pounds of fat a year on your
body so stop drinking your calories is
what I would say
um
water is really important I don't think
anybody says that's not a good thing
your brain is 80
water so your body is 70 water so being
dehydrated by just two percent decreases
your spatial awareness so for race car
drivers absolutely critical to be
hydrated
after this explains after like drinking
if you drink the next day you're
dehydrated and you're like you're just
not sharp you're like you lose your
train of thought your fragmented
thoughts and that's probably from
dehydration of the brain correct
partially so caffeine dehydrates you
alcohol
dehydrates you
um and then just not drinking enough
water
um
high quality protein proteins absolutely
essential for brain function
um healthy fat so I know for a long time
fat was demonized but 60 of the solid
weight of your brain is fat right so
somebody calls you a fat head say thank
you
it's really important avocados nuts and
seeds green leafy vegetables healthy
oils clean sustainable fish all of those
really in fact there's a study from the
Mayo Clinic that people who are on a fat
based diet 42 percent less risk of
getting Alzheimer's disease
people who are on the standard American
diet uh think bread pasta potatoes rice
fruit juice sugar have a 400 percent
increased risk of getting Alzheimer's
disease and so carbs are not the enemy
but there are smart carbs and there are
dumb carbs right and the dumb carbs or
sugar and then foods that quickly turn
to sugar
um
does fruit fall into that
um so I think you should probably have
two or three times the number of
vegetables two fruit but I'm a huge fan
of blueberries they're like my go-to I
had a cup this morning in my shake uh
they should be called brain berries uh
because of the plant medicines that are
in them so I think berries are awesome
plums are amazing it's the high glycemic
fruits that you should be careful with
like mangoes and pineapple and
watermelon dates uh
but you know it's as long as it's not
fruit juice
generally a fan of it
and if you're struggling if you struggle
with anxiety or depression I think it's
a good idea to go on an Elimination Diet
get rid of sugar gluten dairy corn and
soy artificial dyes and sweeteners
um
and I'm shocked at the number of my
patients who don't need me anymore when
they go on the right diet in fact I have
one story I love we saw this guy in our
New York Clinic who'd had ECT
electroconvulsive therapy three times
for depression and had been on every
antidepressant you can imagine and
seeing a therapist for a long time
and I'm like let's try an Elimination
Diet let's eliminate all the potential
Bad actors and you know he was so tired
of trying to be better he's like okay
and no lie within three weeks he's
better he's happy motivated his energy
is better he's not thinking of killing
himself and I'm like all right let's add
back gluten nothing happened
beside back Dairy nothing happened like
let's add back corn he said within 20
minutes he had a vision of a gun in his
mouth pulling the trigger wow well let's
break up with corn
yeah and I love corn
but it doesn't love me back
which you know I love that because
ultimately
you're in a relationship with food
and I don't know if you've ever been in
a bad relationship but I've been in bad
relationships in the past yeah I'm 40.
definitely I'm not doing that anymore
and
I'm damn sure not doing it with food
yeah right I mean I have control and
it's like oh but I love Rocky Road ice
cream
yeah but it doesn't love you back right
and Drew Carey said it best I love he's
a comedian who lost a lot of weight and
he said eating crappy food isn't a
reward
it's a punishment oh and and I knew when
he said that he would stay healthy
because ultimately if you're feeling
deprived
then you're not going to keep doing the
right thing that you have to shift your
mindset to doing the right thing is a
sign of love right and I love me yeah
yeah diet plays such a big role in so
many things
um are there any supplements uh um I
mean I know we've talked about uh Happy
saffron
um but on top of diet are there some
staple supplements that you think
everyone should take
wow I mean so much so I believe in it so
much I started a supplement company yeah
I mean it makes sense I I know that like
I know you've said like you have a
supplement company you recommend them
but you know you make what you want to
have and so I make them for me and I
make money for our family yeah and I
think everybody should take multiple
vitamins and we make neurovite plus
which is just so special because it's
got all the ingredients that I would
want to take that would cost a whole
bunch of money to put it all together
everybody should take an omega-3 fatty
acid supplement and we have a brand new
vegan one that's so special everyone
should know their vitamin D level and
work to optimize it people who had low
vitamin D died from covid more than
people who have healthy levels
um and then it really depends on your
issue that if you tend to be sad I'm a
huge fan of saffron there's a brand new
study out today so it makes the 25th
randomized controlled trial with saffron
showing it helps to boost your mood and
decrease inflammation in your body so I
was pretty excited about that yeah I
like 5-HTP for my Warriors
um I like l-tyrosine for people who uh
have trouble focusing I love ashwagandha
and magnesium and thinning for anxiety
in fact you know I'm not a fan of
alcohol and my wife the other day we
have something here called thinning
gummies and she goes how many can I take
and I'm like well you probably take
three or four if you're really feeling
anxious well she takes three and then
some Gaba with it and she looked drunk I
mean like literally and so I'm thinking
of marketing them as you know my
alternative to wine I will love I would
love to try that for you I would love to
try that I'll do a beta test for you and
let you know how it goes as I of course
do love my wine
um what about uh what about your
emotional state you know what about just
your you know how important that is and
how much control it has like I'm just
you know what about people that heal
themselves and using the power of their
mind how does that happen
well let me get people two strategies
that I use them like a lot the first one
is you need to control your thoughts if
your thoughts are controlling you it's
backwards okay and how you control them
is whenever you feel sad or mad or
nervous or out of control write down
what you're thinking and then ask
yourself whether or not it's true and I
have a process in a number of my books
my new book you happier uh takes you
through five simple questions thank you
takes you through five simple questions
and
and it is
it's emotional Freedom when you don't
have to believe everything you think
like Katie Byron said stop believing
what you think
I love that so much
um
the second thing actually I'm gonna give
you three is when you go to bed tonight
and every night
go what went well today put yourself to
sleep by going on a treasure hunt
looking for what was right about your
day now the bad things will pop up
imagine a big room sweep them away you
can deal with that tomorrow the point is
put yourself to sleep with gratitude and
positivity your sleep will be better and
then when you find you get really upset
there's something called bilateral
stimulation and I do a therapy I love I
just did a session uh called EMDR I'm
movement desensitization and
reprocessing it's so powerful especially
if you've had some trauma in the past
and who hasn't but I also like a cousin
to it called Hayden which is when you
get upset grab your shoulders and just
stroke down and
do it for like 30 seconds and you can do
it like up to six times
and about two and a half years ago my
dad died and it was an awful day and I
had a complicated relationship with my
father but toward the last five years
of my life who's like my best friend and
I was horrified
um and a couple of days later I'm at my
mom's house
and there's a picture of my dead dad in
the mortuary in a stack of papers and it
just like I felt like somebody slugged
me uh it really upset me I couldn't stop
thinking about it I was really angry
somebody would be that thought was
and it's like came home I'm like you
treat people who have this problem
yeah and I and I consciously rather than
get drunk and stop thinking about it I
thought about the picture and I did this
and I noticed after about 30 seconds it
went from on a scale of zero to ten zero
is it doesn't bother you at all 10 is
you're really unhappy about it it was a
10. and it went to five
and then after the third time I did it
it went to zero and then I kept doing it
I did it three more times
and I fell in love with the picture
because it was the last picture of my
dad on Earth and
when you have these tools to manage your
mind and you're also managing your brand
it gives you this emotional freedom
so that you can live in the present
and love your life
I can't imagine how many people that
would help if they just knew that
technique that is not hard to do and
it's also not a thinking exercise
necessarily where you have to because
sometimes when you're in the state of
anxiety or overwhelming sadness or fear
or something it's an inescapable to to
choose a different thought but this
isn't a thought this is an action it's
just so effective but at the same time
don't be afraid of your thoughts right
you have to direct them see I would bet
for you that racing because you were so
good at it was mostly a subconscious
exercise
you just knew what to do because you had
done it for so many years
there's nowhere in school where people
teach you to manage your mind so it's
always conscious managing it where if
you wrote down 30 or 100 of your worst
thoughts and you brought them through
those questions that I write about
pretty soon
subconsciously you get a bad thought
and then you'll flip it and you'll go
well is the opposite of the bad thought
and
but it takes work right you did not
become great
by wishing it you became great by
wanting it and working it if you are
going to have an elite brain and mind
you gotta work it it's like every day
um brain health mental health is a daily
practice and I'm so grateful to you for
having me on so good yeah I could share
my work uh real quick you had mentioned
sleep what is it what is it that's
actually happening when we sleep with
our brain it washes itself it cleans
itself it actually has a fluid system
that is not open during the day but when
you go to sleep it opens it it's called
the glymphatic system so we have
lymphatics in our body yeah and they're
open all day long cleaning up the trash
that builds up well it's closed in your
brain
until you sleep so if you're only
sleeping four hours a night it's like
the cleaning Clue Crew didn't have
enough time to do its job
and so I was when I was talking to Miami
Heat I'm like what if we did a study
where we sort of saw how you know look
at how the players slept and then
they're shooting percentages
because there's a study on soldiers who
get seven hours of sleep or 98 accurate
on the Range but those only get six
hours or 50 percent accurate five hours
they're 35
accurate and four hours are only 15
accurate so what if we made sleep a
priority
and so rather than going out and having
fun going to bed and let the cleaning
crew do their job you're gonna have a
whole bunch more fun tomorrow right so
seven is the magical number
you know probably seven and a half is
the magical number because the brain
tends to sleep in 90 minutes cycles and
so you get five good 90 minute Cycles
this book is really cool you go into
brain types how is it that you're able
to type a brain like there's uh the
spontaneous brain spontaneous balance
persistent sensitive and curious
cautious cautious that's my bad writing
right because everybody has a different
brain yeah
yeah the idea of do these things and be
happy it totally depends on your brain
then the spontaneous type they love
jumping out of airplanes
they love doing high-risk behaviors
um the cautious type not so much that
that actually makes them miserable so
it's very important
to direct happiness to you yeah rather
than one strategy fits everybody that's
just ridiculous and so know your type
who runs toward fires versus people like
me who run away from fires
um there's a very high incidence of ABD
our spontaneous group in firefighters
oh really so
um the persistent people love routine
and ritual and the spontaneous people
hate routine
the persistent people hates surprises
the spontaneous people loves surprises
and so can you imagine if you're married
to someone one's spontaneous the other
is persistent you're not speaking the
same language because your chemistry is
different right right and so ultimately
leading to your happiness and your
emotions being really responsible for
the health of your brain and so you need
to know what kind of brain you have to
know what kind of Lifestyle you should
be curating for yourself to lead to the
healthiest brain I think you break it
down into those four big buckets too the
spirituality and psychology right always
because that's just how I think about
people we don't treat diagnoses we treat
whole people yeah it's so cool that you
have the psychology
um aspect to be able to bring into brain
health so what's uh what's the next um
what's the the next thing you're hoping
to are you working on anything with the
brain is there what's the next Frontier
with the brain maybe something around
Consciousness oh no my big mission in
life and I'd love for you to help me
with it is I want to end mental illness
yeah
I want to end mental illness by creating
a revolution in brain health I hate the
term mental illness I think it shames
people
these are brain health issues that steal
people's minds and so if we can make
brain health cool you know I think me
coming on your podcast that helps uh if
we can make brain health cool
then we can change what is really a
damaging medical specialty you know I
love being a psychiatrist but I hate
what it's turned into you have this
diagnosis based on these symptoms here's
this medicine and we're sicker now than
we have ever been right
cancers decline 27 suicide's gone up 33
why we're working on the wrong Paradigm
so I feel like I have this big mission
so I'm looking for help let's do it okay
what's the call to action what's the
call I want to help promote that so we
actually have a foundation we have a big
event September no I'm sorry December
7th okay so I would love for you to come
but December 7th at the Beverly Hilton
Hotel we're going to have brain healthy
food that is unbelievably delicious
mocktails uh that are so much fun and
um we're gonna brainstorm on how we can
change the conversation away from mental
illness to brain health we actually have
uh preschool course High School course
on called brain Thrive by 25 that
decreases drug alcohol and tobacco use
decreases depression and improves
self-esteem I just I need help because
it's like I'm trying to change culture
when you have Girl Scouts selling
cookies you know that it's probably not
going the right way well you know
there's other there's other certain
things that have happened in the past in
recent time where you get a donut for
something so you know cookies and donuts
are not going to solve the world solve
solve health issues we can I feel like
we can all probably agree with that well
I'm happy to help you with that mission
I love I love brainstorming
um but you know I just really think that
you know thank you for writing so many
books I was trying to figure out how
many books you have and I was like
looking online and I'm like I don't how
many books do you have well I'm old so
I've written a lot I have 40 books
that's insane that's so amazing what a
contribution and I have a new on coming
out in May and then in March called
change your brain every day it's 366
short essays that's cool the most
important things I've ever said because
you know I just came to realize like
physical hell and you've been working on
your physical health and you know it's a
daily practice right from exercise and
eating right and it's you got to do it
every day you can't be 50 pounds
overweight on Monday have a salad for
lunch and expect to be trim on Friday so
no you have to work it the same thing is
true for brain and mental health thank
you so much I really enjoyed getting my
brain scanned if anyone has the
opportunity to get their brain scan you
had 10 clinics
um and there if they have the means to
doing it I highly recommend it it is
um so interesting as well as
um important just to know if you have
the means to do it because uh this is
the motherboard it's it yeah love it
everything in your life is better
cool thank you thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today I hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the Subscribe
button